just being free you know Dominick Cruz
brought this up we're doing commentaries
like some guys fight better with like a
weeks notice
yeah there's no pressure don't just show
up and they're good you know some people
fight better when the underdog nobody's
nobody's thinking they're gonna win no
I'll show you [ __ ] yeah yeah and
you go out there and put on a show I
also think the part of a man that that
part of existing Amanda too isn't when
she's the underdog that's just less
pressure on her so again that's another
distraction away so she just like
alright watches I'm the underdog watch
how I [ __ ] y'all but well y'all put
pressure on me to be the chick you know
to win this fight easily you know I
think she can hold back a little well
she was this favorite against Raquel
Pennington she was a favor against
Raquel and I think that was one of her
best performance yeah well Raquel hung
in there a little bit you know she did
but she had her yeah we kind of had a
round or two you know I don't think she
had a [ __ ] around you think she went
around
she took a man down at one point and had
around mmm
maybe I don't think so I mean I don't
get it I don't think I was I don't think
Amanda was in trouble or anything but
mmm interesting
I think Amanda won every round if I was
if I were calling it correctly I'd have
to go back and look at it but I remember
think it was like a slow steady beat
yeah it was I mean it was I mean it was
pretty it was convincing it was a pretty
easy fight for her but who the [ __ ] was
what's left for her especially like
there's what one legit featherweight
size-wise it's Megan Anderson but Meegan
Gunn exposed a little bit by Holly yeah
you know because Holly took her down and
really dominated her in the clinch and
got her kind of to the ground at will
and I'm sure she's tightened up a lot of
that but she doesn't she's too slow you
think so yeah yeah a lot of people
understand like speed is everything in
this game really more so than size
that's why I was saying about like
cutting weight speed is key in this game
and a lot of people get exposed when
they're not fast enough
you know because and I don't mean
necessarily even just speed and
physically I guess heavyweight speed
physically but like speed and
decision-making right all that speed is
key and I don't think Meegan absents
gonna be have enough speed to deal for
Amanda well you also have the thing the
Meegan Anderson when she fought Holly
Holm that was her UFC debut right
and that is that octagon J [ __ ] is
[ __ ]
we've all had yeah seeing they've all
had it you see that moment where the
bright lights hit you for the first time
you like whoa and they also her first
fight is against Holly [ __ ] home I
know Jesus Christ yeah I mean that's
experienced as you get I mean Holly is
she's it was she's like an 18 time world
boxing champion yeah she was like 27 and
two she has one of the until Amanda
knocked out cyborg she had the greatest
highlight reel ko in a championship
fight yeah yeah in the championship
fight because I think that Jessica and
ROG when she knocked out Karolina
Karolina Kurkova CH yeah yeah that was
that was a bigger knockout then yeah one
not bigger it was right up there yeah it
was right up there but Amanda just took
the [ __ ] cake he's like she's like
out it's mine you think you saw the best
women's MMA ko ever hold my beer yeah
because it's who she did it to I know I
know ah it's everything and surprise I
mean I didn't alive man I was surprised
as much as I love a man that she's you
know she's I hold her dear to my heart I
was even surprised she throws bricks I
know she throat you know what she's like
she's like a bowling ball in the end of
a rope yep boom boom but but if you have
you ever spent time around her and hung
out a little bit out you know at the
fights when she's not fighting backstage
very friendly lesson but this is what
I'm saying
you know like a lot of fighters are like
you know they can have kind of
aggressive personalities yeah she's
nothing like that right I mean she likes
to see their home like she she's got an
Instagram thing like she's cutting the
grass and some flip-flops
she's just so carefree and she just like
she likes to play with her dogs in the
backyard and well I was upset when she
was fighting in Ronda that all the
promos were about Ronda coming back yeah
that Minister off I said before that
before when she when Rhonda was about to
fight Holly home I said that I disagreed
with that fight I said I really think
Amanda Nunez is the most dangerous
challenge
Rhonda I said because amanda has a
Brazilian jiu-jitsu blackbelt and her
hands or what's really scary like when
Rhonda has to close the distance to get
a hold of you when she gets you on the
ground she's armed Barney I'm gonna felt
like Amanda like sizes up with her
that's the most dangerous challenge in
my opinion but then Holly knocked her
out and then when you saw Amanda knock
out Ronda I was like well this how did
you guys not see this coming like this
is not a good matchup and you you spent
the entire promo talking about this one
person who's not the champion who's
coming back after a devastating knockout
and then you didn't show anything about
the one person who is the champion who's
the first openly gay women's champion in
the history of the sport right she's
she's the first gay UFC champion yep and
she's a [ __ ] destroyer
I mean she's exciting as [ __ ] and all
you're showing is Ronda pacing around
her mansion you know Ronda getting
excited about this fight and thinking
I'm gonna go out there and like Jesus
Christ and then backstage here was what
was crazy I was listening to these
agents talk because Rhonda's fights one
of the things that was interesting about
it was she was such a for such a cult of
personality that she had all these
agents and [ __ ] around like all these
like it was all agent of five backstage
so I hear these guys talking and they
let one agent Dork is talking to the
other agent door and he goes who's Ronda
fighting and he's I'm paraphrasing but
his basically said I don't know who she
is but she's a victim uh-huh
like I don't know who it is what's call
her today so they really thought that no
idea what was going on they had no idea
I mean look that's what they were hoping
they were hoping that Ronda wins because
she's this gigantic superstar like if
Ronda comes back beats Amanda Nunez wins
the title back rematch is holly holm
beats Holly home yes she's back but
instead she gets marked and 48 seconds I
mean Amanda just hold it so and I was
saying to them after his leg goes this
is what I was telling you like how the
[ __ ] are you not promoting her like what
she just did if you put equal time
promoting her
you got a new star in your hands instead
the story is Ronda Rousey got smashed
the story's not Amanda yes that's where
they really dropped the ball even
afterwards a DA didn't pick up what
Amanda yes
yeah I agree but it's crazy to me like
it's crazy me to think that they thought
that this was gonna be
Rhonda's comeback to start them because
and I sent you to breakdown I think that
genre of you saw it but because I asked
out all Amanda's opponents and I do to
break down I come up with strategies for
her and after scouting Ronda I said
there's gonna be easy fight for you and
I told her that yeah I said this is
gonna be easy and and it turned out to
be easy and it just surprises me that
they thought that this was gonna be to
come out I don't know and I don't I
didn't talk to Dana about it I told Dana
before I thought it was a terrible
matchup for right but that was before
the Holly Holm fight no no no well he
was saying you need I don't know he
thought that I was saying that Holly
Holm that Rhonda was gonna beat Holly
might well I'm not saying that's easy
either
that's a tough fight too yeah but the
thing about Amanda is punching power
Holly's not known for a punch I know
she's known for speed or kicks her
timing her technique her toughness yes
she's known for all her athletics
physical strength yet she's known for
all those things she's not known just to
go in there blast girls yeah I command a
blast people she puts him into another
dimension she's different in that
respect but they didn't concentrate on
that at all Mike how are you not
concentrating on this destroyer that
Rhonda's about to face but show them
Miesha Tate fight and people would just
be like Jesus yeah
beats the [ __ ] out of her and then
strangles are like do you like I know
that's why it surprised me that they
slept on Amanda how you're sleeping on
cuz it's Hollywood man